how important is the first kiss in a
romantic comedy it is maybe the most
important moment followed closely by the
one towards the end where the two people
realize and admit to each other their
love for each other but that first kiss
wow that's that's amazing that's that's
when you're standing on the threshold of
paradise and that's when you know
whether or not it's going to work
because if that kiss does not transport
your characters does not turn on all the
lights and all the bells and whistles
and the fireworks and all the people
talk about in poetry and literature for
thousands and thousands of years if
that's not there there's no story
there's no story so building up to the
first kiss you need to have that tension
that push-pull so that when you get
there and the positive and the negative
come together
sparks do fly thinking of pretty woman
so there's the implication of sex
there's definitely the you know the sort
of the agreement the business
arrangement but but I'm trying to
remember does that actually happen until
they actually have the first kiss and
actually feel something for one another
that's when it happens okay is it that
first kiss yes now I think they've been
feeling a comradeship
they've been feeling admiration they've
been having fun they've been finding
that they do agree on some things and
not others and so there is an affinity
there's definitely an affinity and
you're right they presumably have been
having sex and she's a pro so okay you
figure it's got to be pretty good but
that moment of actually kissing is when
the magic really starts to happen
and that also now remember she was a
professional escort there is a reason
why among people who are sex workers
there's no kissing allowed because that
creates a let's say an energetic
electrical etheric esoteric connection
between people that really does
something it can change everything it
seems like to with those two characters
once they got out of their roles because
his role of was of the here I'm gonna
pay you and you're kind of beneath me
and I'm I'm this prestigious businessman
and she's like oh who do you think you
are and I've seen the guys like you
you're a dime a dozen
but once they got out of those
identities and they became real that's
when it seemed like the real kiss and
the real sort of relationship happened
because they stopped being their element
sort of yeah that's a good point when
they just became themselves and not the
masks and not the costumes I like that I
like that there's a wonderful line in
Jerry Maguire before they have sex the
first time and he says you know sex
changes everything and she says oh I
hope so and what I love too is the
sister and I want to talk about that the
sister in Jerry Maguire and the
wonderful scene where she's having her
women's group and he comes in and you
can just tell he there's a few women in
the crowd that made me look at him with
a Deering and endearing eyes but they're
just daggers pointed his way and just
the the Jiminy Cricket friend either the
one that's either trying to talk them
out of it or the one that's trying to
talk them into the relationship I I want
to talk about that role of the the third
person that sort of either tries to
bring them together or separate them
when I first started selecting films for
the book Ken Lee publisher said you have
to include trainwreck
I went train wreck I wouldn't even go
see that I said why would I want know
this
about people's relationships getting
better you'd want to see trainwreck he
said go see trainwreck I could not
believe it it's really good and it has
in it the qualities of joy and dignity
and passion and integrity I was so
surprised now one of the reasons it does
is because the Jiminy Cricket character
the best friend is LeBron James okay
that works and he is best friends with
Bill Hader and he sees something in Amy
Schumer he sees what she can be and he
convinces the two of them to get back
together and to admit their feelings for
each other
so that's a wonderful instance of that a
different kind of love triangle that
you've pointed out where you've got the
lovers and then that third person who
helps them see what it is that they have
or what they could have let's see when
the third person is actually trying to
prevent them from being together because
it's like if you take pretty woman and I
forget his name but you know George
Costanza character on Seinfeld the one
that that's his business partner and
pretty and and and he's kind of this
negative force and and and sort of
antagonizing them so that third person
as the one that's trying to prevent them
from being together yes you need the
third person either helping them because
they're not wanting to get together or
as you described trying to keep them
apart well you need that for dramatic
tension and also we need the secondary
characters to help tell us things about
the main characters so they can make
those statements you know when you say
oh I can't have them I can't have him
saying that he'd never say that about
himself we'll give the line to his
friend or give the line to her friend
who says ah you have you no idea what
this guy's like so they the third
character yes it's very very important
in any script all of the secondary
characters need some
how to be showing us something about the
main characters or they don't need to be
there now whether it's they are people
that the main characters do something to
or with or for but they are there to
service the main characters in the story
telling
you